thank you
[Music]
are you guys aware of the iPhone 14 yeah
it's coming for me next Friday you
ordered it already you ordered it are
you stoked on it I'm so shallow guys I
have to have the newest thing what's the
new new dope [ __ ] about it it's purple
that's it that's it you guys said that
as if it's a small thing yeah it's small
it's never been purple before the whole
thing to prepare is the camera the
camera's supposed to be a little bit
better I know about 10 times is it a
special purple didn't they take away
something at the bottom it's called Deep
Purple oh and there's oh there's a on
top there's a thing called what they
call it something Island like so it
apparently has a lot of information in
that little so instead of a notch it's
got like I guess when you notification
center but they call it something
something Island I forgot what it's
called I just got it I didn't like
really like it I didn't need to be
convinced I don't even have the 13 I
have this you're the ideal application
so this is what's he's considered an
early adopted this is what Steve Jobs's
daughter
um said on her Instagram
after the review what did she say me
upgrading from iPhone 13 to 14 after
Apple's announcement today
you're the same [ __ ] shirt yes you do
you that's you being like do it has like
a little strip but I don't know what it
does but like you know it gives you
information or something I'm sorry
timeout did I not mention that it's
purple exactly because like hey look
this is the 13.
that's blue sky blue right let's see if
you see the way okay what if I just
[ __ ] smash it it's covered do you get
the new one every year yeah wow
yeah you don't buy anything used
did you just find out you can buy used
[ __ ] wait what do you mean you like he
might not have even known this home he
gets a new dog every year car outside
2022. oh it's getting kind of old yeah I
did oh you need to get rid of that my
dog will never die get a new dog every
year when you say used do you mean like
someone else used it and then they sell
it yeah okay I'm not you never heard of
that I'm not understanding that really
have you heard about her what do you
think is inside Goodwill have you heard
of thrift shops like Thrifty the ice
cream no no no no there's a store yeah
that's used ice cream where people
donate pecan praline right wait people
don't know they donate clothing
furniture and he could go in for a good
price but yeah that's where I drop off
my old phone but someone else wore it
that's nasty like you have all their
dirt on you yeah I mean you wash it yeah
you can wash it so you you don't care if
Apple's innovating you just want the new
model every year like for you it's just
like you buy the hype you'd love it and
that's fine by the way you're allowed to
do this you're allowed to sound like a
[ __ ] idiot right now no it's fine you
know there's nothing that brings me more
joy than when a white guy says I can do
something
you feel so empowered don't you
yeah no
Innovation like what else what else can
happen with longer battery life better
okay
one thing that could happen is I do wish
the front-facing camera and the back
facing camera was equal quality okay
because one's like one's like [ __ ] one's
super good because they don't know that
we Vlog when the Blackberry came out you
know what people said [ __ ] like that
yeah oh dude what's next nothing but
okay like no but I really I put a lot of
thought into this like what what could
possibly happen to a phone I'll give you
two things please don't please do on fob
your voice
so you sound like hello yes this is
Walter yeah you said they do that though
they have they have to yeah but it'll be
built in second one remove all traces of
Photoshop from people's photos when
you're viewing them through your phone
whoa wait that's a privacy concern yeah
that's also I don't want to know that
all my friends are ugly um so what about
what about if they uploaded the newest
album by you too oh oh yeah delayed it's
not the oldest one not the not the ones
you say the oldest one or the the newest
the newest one not the old one from like
five years ago no no the new YouTube so
what if they uploaded for free yeah for
free it's like it's a it's a give me you
know it's a lucky day like and then when
I download it no it's just already
pre-loaded it's preloaded it's cool I
probably wouldn't listen to it but you
know oh well you probably have to I'll
give you a third one I'll give you a
bonus one yes on the new phone you can
hear what people are saying while they
are waiting for you to pick up so you
can hear them go let me call this
[ __ ] right now
okay so you you you're into just
throwing privacy out the window is
basically
I got a wild idea how about I don't have
to update it every 30 minutes yeah dude
I think that'd be [ __ ] crazy actually
come consist of [ __ ] downloading
viruses on your phone so it [ __ ] up
after a year and you gotta buy a new one
that's why I haven't uploaded my updated
but he's immune to that how about it's
not a closed system I can actually get
it
upload all my photos to it without it
[ __ ] deleting all my photos oh that's
called Droid go you go to delete all my
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying feel free
[ __ ] I gotta keep this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] because of that I want a Droid you
can't do that they cannot take all of
your [ __ ] and then just put it into the
news yeah it's called iCloud it's an app
bro there's actually an app that does
that bro it overwrites your old [ __ ]
dude the Verizon app it actually puts it
on their Cloud yeah see why doesn't
Apple want to do that for me though wait
they do have a clock yeah apple can do
it yeah no apple can do it it just takes
[ __ ] forever yeah you got to leave
your phone just like 12 hours but I'll
do it yeah but why would you want to go
from Mercedes down to like Honda Civic
is what I would ask
um because it's cheaper because Too Fast
Too Furious I keep I feel like I'm not
saying it properly yeah let me see it
this purpose
I need to Picture This is it a a prince
purple or is it more like a a grape
purple they call it deep purple it's not
it's the purple it's called Deep Purple
yeah yeah no it's not that what happened
to just the black one they have that too
oh
look the gold ones were the best ones
what color MacBook you have you got a
[ __ ] rose gold one I don't have I
actually don't have a Macbook what yeah
you got a Droid [ __ ] laptop I don't
have a laptop I have an iMac that's not
purple it's like sky blue man what color
iMac you have that's not purple at all
that's the performance one so they only
kind of one color but if I got the other
one I'd probably get whatever however
whatever color I feel like that day hey
why Dave what the [ __ ] why do I only
have two kids this isn't the pro that's
not the pro that's just the 14. well you
said that was fine oh you got the how
much is a 14.
I get the 256 gig it's 1100.
you still pay a thousand dollars for the
new one no I'm part of the Jump program
the Apple like Pro program so I just pay
monthly oh okay yeah well so like yeah
no so like I don't like cases because it
then it covers up the beautiful color
they do make it a very beautiful phone
yeah and then I don't like the bulk in
my pocket but if you're clumsy like me
if you don't have a case it's [ __ ]
trash Bart uses his phone as a [ __ ]
cup holder yeah like not not gonna load
I don't I don't drop my phone I might
crack my phone all the time no you take
care of your [ __ ] I don't know why you
can't actually dropped their phone all
the time actually I I didn't know that
white men Korean men we do not really we
hold out the things we like you hold on
right now
we don't just let them go
yeah it's pretty good man
I'm intimidated he's done that before
he's got a new one on the way he'll let
you break it
that's true and all we gotta do when you
get your new phone you gotta come back
and then give a performance review of
the new phone and then you're going to
be super [ __ ] like underwhelmed with
how long it is yeah so it has this like
it has this like app on it I don't know
what
it
would a phone compare it with your old
one and hook you up to a [ __ ]
polygraph and you tell us why it's
better that thing's gonna start smoking
I'll tell you every phone I get I don't
like start new like I just uh upload my
old phone into my new one right so it
always looks the same like it just
doesn't feel different same background
but recently Apple deleted my data what
yeah it was this whole long story but
like um long story short what a great
company they didn't tell me they just go
hey because they thought that when they
told me that the logic was logical was
gonna be replaced that I would know that
it's gonna be a race but I don't even
know what the logic board is or whatever
you know what that is exactly just an
apple consumer so then when I when I
started over fresh it felt so cool like
I got a new phone it feels
technologically advanced so on this new
one I may not upload
my uh current phone into it I may just
kind of like just download app by app
again yeah just make you like that
experience what about your cool photos
of the stuff where you can put that well
that'll put on my computer oh yeah I'll
put on my computer and then just
download those later but like yeah that
feeling of like oh like it's because you
know when you get a phone it's not like
you're like looking at it all day it's
just you're just looking at when you're
using it so most of it is when you're on
it and you're in it then you're like oh
it has to feel new for me because it's
new okay but like that doesn't feel new
but like you know when I look at I'm
like oh yeah this is cool but when you
buy something used it's still new to you
because it's new can you go back to the
used concept I don't quite understand
how much do you get off on on the
unboxing experience and the little pills
okay yeah when you say get off yeah I
don't get off anymore and I'll tell you
why okay Apple has been skimping I I
read an article on the packaging let me
skip the packages no it's not the same
you know before you used to be able to
hold the package and it would slowly
yeah yeah exactly it doesn't do that as
well anymore because they've gotten rid
of a lot of like the the um
Indulgence is that [ __ ] Tim Cook
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think it's the guy below him that
does the design stuff I know like Johnny
Ivey he left it was like some other guy
you know and these guys are all super
Petty as soon as one of them leaves the
projects that they say no to they
immediately put on so like I don't know
if you guys remember the iPhone
originally to delete email you swiped
right and it made sense because most
people held their phone with their left
hand and they swiped right to get rid of
an email well one of the guy that guy
left and the guy below him was like I
hate that and he made it left are we
that [ __ ] spoiled we need to like
dude programmers are honestly the
[ __ ] worst oh yeah no programmers
there's nerds we'll make things that's
why Steve Jobs did so well right he made
he simplified things for the consumer
for the end user but programmers will
overly complicate [ __ ] like have you
updated your [ __ ] on accident because I
did recently and the [ __ ] calendar on
the phone is a goddamn nightmare again
it's a goddamn nightmare I used to know
what the [ __ ] was going on calendar and
now when I open up my calendar I'm like
holy [ __ ] that's how it looks yeah
that's how it looks that's [ __ ]
don't don't update your [ __ ] dude I'm
not going to I haven't I haven't yeah
you guys should see the very opposite
mine's an automatic update yeah mine
updates you would do that yeah I had I
automatically update everything I just
want to know what day it is to do I
don't want to see all my [ __ ] yeah are
you on an automatic upgrade too for
whatever the new phone comes out it just
takes the money from your account I wish
it was automatic it's not I had to wake
up at five this morning to reserve it no
I had reserved it before but then to
finish it off you have to do it at five
in the morning
what a great and it did it over to five
it didn't open at five it was 502. is
this controversial because his own
daughter is like not putting her stab of
approval on it and she's just laughing
about it the idea is that uh Steve Jobs
rolling in his grave and has been since
he left Apple tell him what's Steve Jobs
daughter's name is Eve
Steve Jobs Steve and Eve pretty good
right right
I thought it was because it's apple he
also has a daughter named Lisa oh that's
cool well that's the one that he is well
he named the computer after that later
but he still told her no it's not after
you yeah I just like the name Lisa yeah
I know it's kind of a [ __ ] up weird
thing but kind of weird kind of strange
wait where is it from huh Lisa what's
her name Lisa's the daughter he would
acknowledge that was her name yeah whoa
he he said that that's not my daughter
for a long time and then but then at the
same time he created a new a computer at
Apple and called it the Lisa and then
like yeah she confronted him about it
and he still was like no it's not after
you the later he got to it
wow he's a troubled man I heard he's a
he's quite the [ __ ] face well he was an
[ __ ] as like the whole thing but what
he did was incredible like obvious I
mean so many times like Pixar apple
right he did the next which was his
biggest failure but he wasn't a ship
face to the consumer that's what I love
no exactly he made it so easy
he fired the stupid programmers who did
stupid [ __ ] where he's like why is this
over the complicated why can't people
just use it and that's why when the
iPhone came out your mom could use it
for the first time ever your a new piece
of technology comes out your parents
could use because he just made it like
oh yeah you can just [ __ ] zoom in
zoom out exactly and then intuitive he
made you know they kept pushing him
let's make a bigger filming before he's
like no because I want people to build
user with one hand yeah and so like the
five iPhone five is the last one where
it was thin I think now it's the mini
that you can use one hand but they're
gonna they make they may discontinue it
but as they got bigger you can't use the
one here you know when you're driving
yeah yeah you have to like balance your
phone and then you're and then it gets
on then you drive all crazy I'm trying
to go 100 miles an hour how like how am
I gonna do it like this exactly this is
so hard yeah
stupid [ __ ] programmers don't know
human beings and [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you